michaela school is in good spirits but
her parents are not optimistic about her
future prospects they're desperate to
see her escape poverty the family lives
in mod rich in the southwest of
bosnia-herzegovina
close to the Croatian border there's no
work here the old state enterprises were
shut down before the war the area has
still not recovered from the devastation
of the balkan wars of the 1990s but the
people here most of them bosnian croats
ly privileged lives compared to other
parts of the country qualifying as by
nationals means they can work in Croatia
the family's oldest daughter already
lives there and with Croatia about to
join the EU Mikaela also hopes for new
opportunities this is the day they
commemorate the dead in mod rich and
many natives have returned home for the
observance some drive cars with German
or Austrian license plates
I have Croatian citizenship and I think
a lot of people will move not just to
Austria but all over Europe the EU has
always attracted itinerant laborers now
white-collar workers have the
opportunity to emigrate there in many
cases for good young members of this
church will soon be able to go to
university in the EU
thanks to their Croatian passports
but the anticipated brain drain could
mean new problems for the patchwork
state of bosnia-herzegovina especially
in mostar the largest city in the
southwest of the country the conflicts
of the 1990s left bad blood between
ethnic crow hats and Muslim Bosniaks
many cravat still refused to recognize
the country they share with Bosniaks and
insist on autonomy the divisions still
persist but Harris Idris and morena JH
want to bring young people together at
the mostar Youth Council one recent
joint art project involved the painting
of this ruin he's bosniak while morena
is ethnic Croatian in their view every
young person who leaves the city means
one less symbol of a shared peaceful
future for those with Croatian passports
at least previous barriers to the EU are
now gone Harris is a teacher this school
in most our classes are taught
separately according to ethnic and
religious background we talked to some
of the cravat students during lunch
break and hear about their big plans to
me I want to go visit my brother in
Nuremberg and learn German and then go
to college there eventually plan your
attack on us Harris's Bosnia pupils do
not have that option it adds to the
youngsters frustration it's not fair
they have dual citizenship and can work
here and in Croatia that's how the law
is and the laws made by the state is Ark
Winnipeg that would be Bosnian law which
has yet to deal with this issue
Croatia's accession could initially mean
a step back for Bosnia a step back in
terms of peaceful inter-ethnic relations
in mostar while rural communities like
mckaela's may see the numbers of young
people declining still further